yes how's it going bros my name is Pippa
but ever gonna place a man who can bed
I'm a noob at this game but I love it
and I think it'll be a lot of fun and
we're gonna play against photo mingle
I'm gonna play sukira which is the only
character I know how to play because I
don't know what I'm doing really scoop
but this game kind of forces me to
actually focus on the game and I love
this game I think it's it's really fun
so hopefully I won't lose which is also
part of the fun cuz we don't know what's
gonna I mean they don't know right but I
think I've been doing too well and now I
get to play against people who are
actually good at the game
thanks I'm gonna start by slapping him
laughs oh God oh the uppercuts I don't
[ __ ] understand why people keep
spamming them it's so boring
it just way too much damage I don't like
it look at this come here
oh I missed very bad very not good he's
gonna pick up me see
apricot Africa [ __ ] no you we're guys
gonna forget me hey hey
[Music]
uppercut [ __ ] sorry I got a lot of
anger from people spamming uppercut
uppercut me then look you did it
apricot me no can't do that you did it
[ __ ] [ __ ] I need a shape out hey look my
term job briquette big dammit miss Oh
God look at this oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate
this [ __ ] uppercuts no this is really
very bad yes let me nipple pierced
nipple pierced there we go
thought I was gonna miss the nipple
pierce the nipple pierce will come to
you all
sorry I miss here have an ornament that
was fun let's see if he wants to play
again do you mind every match yes he was
that's not how it goes
come on uppercut me then your [ __ ]
car conniving lows upper cut upper cut
this oh you did it no no poor you nice
uppercuts everybody good I really have
no right to complain about uppercuts but
IRA have to do yeah every time bro like
how many times you're gonna not do that
I'm not even slapping you I'm gonna slap
him now look at this look at this slap
slap don't ever cut me breath know what
I say what oh wow no don't ever cut me
it hurt yeah nice spin you did there
[ __ ] hurts my feelings I'm dead now
I'm dead now [ __ ] dead I did it I did
it
yeah okay oh god don't [ __ ] this up
[Music]
that's a piercing it's the only fatality
I know I know
sorry about that I try so hard but I
keep failing does he want to play again
and with this little leper Kurtz come on
baby
uppercut me yes he will okay I'll give
him one more chance
aren't you gonna uppercut made out of
Warriors slap it's wrapping time I have
not slept this man oh oh no no no no and
now it's time for traffic jam when would
you learn that that [ __ ] don't work on
me
Wow no Raqqah waterful slapping time
oh don't hurt my feeling nice one breath
what I delicious no no no no this very
bad for you I block I swear you did it
you did it you opera views you
successfully no shame on you shame on
you all right I said it
someone had to say it no warning
stop what I say no you're so desperate
you're so different
a little bit [ __ ] you
no I'm not dead yet I'm dead [ __ ] up
this it is the end of me you're right
let me slap enough in the ocean
pure [ __ ]
oh you got me [ __ ] hurts me more than
anyone very bad for me this is really
bad for me
[ __ ] hell I'm gonna clog ah oh he got
me
oh so close ah [ __ ]
I bet he's happy he didn't let me slap
him that's the problem
I wear any when you ever were to play
again
oh he levelled up even I bet he's happy
come on all right I'm pissed now I'm
gonna [ __ ] him I'm gonna [ __ ] you be
ready
I'm gonna slap the [ __ ] out of him it's
gonna be good nice move [ __ ] oh oh
[ __ ] uppercut man so [ __ ] sick of
all the [ __ ] uppercuts oh nice
what I don't even know how sorry that
was that was so unnecessary
[ __ ] you in those [ __ ] uppercuts
whatever the [ __ ] that is
[Music]
I'm not gonna [ __ ] x-ray that [ __ ]
I'm not a [ __ ] idiot
netball tears this is what you get on an
[ __ ] this game this game brings out
the worst in me no [ __ ] you and your
[ __ ] uh poor guys I play against
someone else jimson hey okay we're gonna
do one more fight and then that'll be it
I'm very tired brother see you I didn't
even know Jason was in this game just
Christ what are you doing here Jane
Jason what's that sound
shut up you're scaring me Jason out
there is that what you're saying I don't
like this I have never seen Jason I
don't know what he can do I'm gonna slap
him though I'm gonna suck the [ __ ] out
of men look at this Jason look at this
Jason
no Jason you did it Jason he's scaring
me I don't like this
he's he's cutting me that's offensive no
Jason stop Jason he's scaring the [ __ ]
out of me I don't like this
now you go Jason there you go Jason I
don't like to stay some good hey go
Jason [ __ ] you Jason
[Music]
- for
[ __ ] you Jason you want to play
defensively [ __ ] your mom so [ __ ]
focus that [ __ ] song socks in my ass
yo oh I'm done so hard I gotta go this
has been great I can't believe I [ __ ]
beat him it was so much [ __ ] better
into me he just taste that I want to see
how he reacts I can tell I can smell
your anger Jason what are you gonna do
yeah
you know what I'm gonna do [ __ ] off
little like if you enjoyed if you want
more let me know please tell me how to
get better this game because I do want
to learn and I'll see you both in the
next one
stay awesome